nbc smash hit sitcom the office
captivated audiences
as it unfolded in a nine season run from
2005 to 2013
and now we're breaking down exactly what
happened during the show so let's dig
deep into the entire story of the office
let's kick things off at the beginning
shall we the story of the office begins
in 2005 when a film crew from pbs
arrives at the scranton branch of the
dunder mifflin paper company to make a
documentary about the shifting landscape
of american office life
there they meet michael scott a former
paper salesman who's risen through the
ranks to become the regional manager of
the branch and the various characters
who populate his staff
though the documentary crew perhaps
didn't intend to stay long they are
quickly sucked into the various
shenanigans around the office
including the wild ideas of top salesman
dwight schrute and the obvious
flirtation between salesman jim halbert
and receptionist pam beasley
at the beginning of their tenure the
crew documents the hiring of new temp
worker ryan howard
and perhaps sensing that there's much
more drama to mind they end up staying
at dunder mifflin scranton through major
change after major change for the next
nine years
rumors soon begin to swirl throughout
the company that downsizing may be
coming in the near future
healthcare plans are slashed and michael
lets employee devin white go on
halloween through a fungal painful
display of incompetence
in spite of this michael tries his best
to increase company morale through less
than successful memes which include a
haphazard basketball game between the
office and warehouse workers an
impromptu birthday party for alcoholic
meredith palmer and a botched christmas
gift exchange
perhaps the best boost for the employees
attitudes comes in the form of an
undercover reading of michael's
screenplay threat level midnight along
with a healthy dose of office-based
olympics
around this time michael buys a condo
and begins juggling a complicated pair
of relationships with his realtor carol
stills
and his superior jan levinson meanwhile
beat-loving salesman dwight schrute and
uptight accountant angela martin begin a
secret relationship
and by january 2006 jim breaks up with
his girlfriend katie
not long after this michael reveals to
corporate that he's been in a
relationship with jan although he
manages to explain that it wasn't
serious enough to warrant termination
and as spring turns to summer jim
finally expresses his feelings to pam
and kisses her however she stays with
her fiance warehouse worker roy anderson
although they break up soon afterward
and jim takes a job at the stamford
branch of dunder mifflin
back in the scranton office ryan the
temp finally goes full time
michael kicks off the fall of 2006 by
outing and then kissing gay accountant
oscar martinez who gets a three-month
paid vacation as a result
the manager follows this up by
dramatically shepherding the office
through grief counseling after receiving
news of the unexpected death of former
manager ed truck
this all leads to a crescendo late in
the year when jan informs michael that
the scranton branch is being closed
however when the stamford manager josh
porter ditches his managerial duties for
a job with staples the script is flipped
and scranton ends up absorbing the
stamford branch bringing jim back to
pennsylvania in the process
we did it we did it we did it
the merger of the two branches is a
rough one and by early 2007 andy bernard
and karen phillippelli who also happens
to be jim's new girlfriend
are the only original stamford employees
remaining later pam's ex-fiance roy is
fired when he tries to assault jim after
learning that he kissed
pam dwight is also framed by andy and
fired although he's quickly rehired
afterward
this period of time also sees a lot of
drama in the relationship department
carol breaks up with michael who steers
into the relationship with jan as a
result
salesman phyllis lapin also ties the
knot with bob vance advanced
refrigeration and heads off on a
six-week honeymoon
soon after the wedding michael
interviews with cfo david wallace to
replace jan at the corporate office but
ultimately that job goes to ryan howard
who becomes the youngest vp in the
company's history
in the aftermath of ryan howard's
promotion jim breaks up with karen and
finally hooks up with pam
angela privately breaks up with dwight
after mercy kills her cat and she begins
dating andy openly
michael continues to date jan who helps
him organize a charity fun run to raise
funds for rabies awareness after he hits
meredith with his car
yes those two events are connected turns
out
meredith has been exposed to rabies
which is like 10 times worse than a
little crack
in your pelvis meanwhile looking to make
a splash ryan attempts to launch a
company website called dunder mifflin
infinity
the site goes live in october 2007 but
six months later it's dead in the water
and ryan has been arrested for
misleading the shareholders as dunder
mifflin struggles jan sues the company
unsuccessfully for wrongful termination
she also bankrupts michael and then the
two break up after throwing the world's
worst dinner party
i'll be your first customer you're
hardly my first
throughout the chaos jim and pam's
fledgling relationship soars
jim attempts to propose to pam in early
2008 but andy steals his thunder by
proposing to angela first at the
farewell party for toby flenderson
the hr rep who's leaving for costa rica
toby is replaced by holly flax who
immediately hits things off with michael
because the two are just so perfectly
dorky together
the rest of 2008 is fairly quiet as far
as the office is concerned
the biggest events are the return of
ryan howard his attempt and the transfer
of holly flax to the nashua branch after
david wallace discovers that she and
michael are dating
this effectively breaks a couple up
although the two are still interested in
each other
jim and pam's relationship also comes
under serious pressure for the first
time when pam leaves for three months to
attend art school in new york city
jim proposes to her while she's away and
eventually she returns after failing to
complete the course
not long after this jim buys his parents
house without telling pam and then
surprises her with it as a gift
as the year wraps up things take a major
turn despite the fact that she's engaged
to andy
angela has been having an affair with
dwight but that all comes crashing down
when phyllis exposes angela's infidelity
and early in 2009 the two salesmen duel
with each other over their co-worker
however by the time it's over both
combatants have decided to bitterly
break things off with angela
in early 2009 michael and pam go on a
dunder mifflin lecture circuit where
michael reveals his masterfully dramatic
recipe for success to everyone who will
listen to him
afterward david wallace hires charles
miner to fill ryan's old job
charles immediately clashes with michael
who quits after one day of working with
the new supervisor
having little experience outside of the
paper market michael decides to start
his own paper company and convinces pam
and ryan to join him
after a short run of artificial success
the trio uses the michael scott paper
company as leverage to get jobs back at
dunder mifflin
pam is promoted to sales while aaron
hannon stays on as the new receptionist
after this pam and jim discover they're
going to have a kid as they tend to an
injury pam received at a company picnic
they managed to keep the pregnancy a
secret until the fall when the rumor
mill accidentally leaks the information
in the interim dunder mifflin closes
their buffalo camden and yonkers
branches and it's clear the company is
on the way to bankruptcy
in the fall of 2009 jim and michael are
made co-managers in order to spread out
the increased workload caused by all of
the branch closings
the dynamic duo lead the office through
the ensuing months during which
dunder mifflin goes under and is bought
by the printer company's sabre
as thunder mifflin tanks jim and pam's
relationship reaches new heights as they
get hitched in niagara falls
a deliberately planned destination
wedding they hope their co-workers will
skip but despite the distance the entire
office tags along for the ride once
sabre ceo
joe bennett and her lackey gabe lewis
arrive on the scene jim quickly returns
to sales
and michael resumes soul command of the
dunder mifflin managerial throne the
applicable daryl philbin is promoted
during this time as well and begins to
fulfill his duties from the office
rather than the warehouse
in march 2010 a very pregnant pam spends
an entire fearful day at the office
before being talked into going to the
hospital where she gives birth to
cecilia halper
with the heavy days of perpetual
downsizing behind them for the time
being the scranton office enters a
period of relative stability
toby returns from costa rica and pam
who's miserable in sales
creates a position of office
administrator out of thin air and then
awards it to herself as a promotion
as 2010 draws to a close toby spends a
chunk of time out of the office serving
as a juror on the case of the scranton
strangler
this leads to holly temporarily
returning as a fill-in giving michael
the chance to convince her to date him
once again
and soon the two lovebirds are back
together early 2011 sees the
over-the-top romantic couple get engaged
and then move away together to boulder
colorado where they plan to help holly's
aging parents
hey will you guys let me know if this
ever airs the departure of michael scott
leaves the office scrambling yet again
to fill the void
initially michael trains d'angelo
vickers to replace him
however soon after taking the job
deangelo is seriously injured while
performing a basketball stunt and the
office finds itself leaderless again
sabre ceo joe bennett swoops into the
rescue and offers dwight the position of
acting manager for the time being
but dwight finds himself relegated back
to the bullpen after accidentally firing
a loaded gun in the office
joe then sets up a search committee
which finally settles on the
uncomfortably eccentric robert
california as the new regional manager
he promptly convinces joe bennett to
give him her own job and then hires andy
bernard as his replacement
as 2011 plays out robert california
plays mind games with his new staff and
puts unreasonable pressure on andy to
push the office to overperform
andy on the other hand takes some time
to acclimate to his new position of
authority
initially struggling to handle crises
like the warehouse workers winning the
lottery and all quitting at once
he also begins dating jessica one of the
few repeat characters in the show that
actually works outside of the office and
the greater story
in the meantime kathy sims has hired his
attempt to replace pam while she's on
maternity leave with her second child
phillip
angela gives birth to her first child
who's also named phillip and who she
claims to have had with her husband
senator robert lipton
yet another extracurricular character
from outside the office who met angela
back in late 2010.
in early 2012 dwight leads a team from
dunder mifflin scranton down to
tallahassee florida where they work in
the sabre headquarters for three weeks
on a project led by nelly bertram
the group is tasked with designing a new
retail store for the printer company
however the entire situation goes south
when robert california deliberately
nixes the idea and soon everyone finds
themselves back in scranton
it's during this time that andy ditches
jessica heads to florida to fetch
ex-girlfriend aaron and reignites a
relationship with the receptionist
however when the couple returns to
scranton andy finds he's been usurped by
nelly who's taken the manager position
on the grounds that andy had abandoned
his responsibilities
not long after this joe bennett
liquidates the entire saber company just
in time for david wallace to return to
the scene as a new investor
he reinstates andy is the manager while
nelly is allowed to stay on as an
employee
in late 2012 andy receives news that his
family has gone bankrupt which leads him
to taking an undisclosed three-month
break so that he can sail the family
yacht to the caribbean in order to sell
it
upon his return a justifiably angry
aaron breaks up with him and starts
dating the new customer service rep pete
miller
while all that drama is happening jim
starts to work part time after going all
in on his own sports marketing company
in philly a business called
athlete this new focus quickly escalates
and by early 2013 jim and pam's
relationship is under serious strain
they begin attending marital counseling
and eventually jim realizes that he
can't continue dividing his time between
billy and scranton
he returns to dunder mifflin full time
late in the spring
this all coincides with andy bernard's
third and final abrupt departure from
the company when he quits in order to
pursue an acting career in
his wake dwight at long last is truly
unquestionably crowned as the regional
manager of dunder mifflin scranton
plus it finally comes out that angela's
son isn't the senators but dwight's
in may 2013 pbs airs the documentary
that's been 10 years in the making
this grant office is officially no
longer being watched by a documentary
crew around the clock
over the following year new regional
manager dwight schrute makes several
changes
including rehiring devin and firing
accountant kevin malone who buys
his own bar plus salesman stanley hudson
finally retires to a hideaway in florida
where he spends his time alone carving
wooden figurines
a year after the documentary airs the
film crew catches up with everyone in
order to gather bonus footage for the
dvd release
dwight and angela are officially married
around this time and michael scott
arrives as a surprise guest at the
wedding revealing that he's very happy
living his life with holly and their
kids in colorado
we also learned that pam has been
plotting to sell the halpert house and
move her family to austin texas
so jim can resume his career with
athlete with everyone's lives officially
moving forward many in directions other
than the office
the epic tale of america's favorite
workplace finally comes to an end
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one